[Musique]
alors les panélistes défilent cette
émission elle ne se ressemblent pas José
Legault Michel coger Sébastien Bovet
merci d'être avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir à tous les trois alors
j'aimerais parler peut-être de Dominique
Anglade en fait elle était la seule la
chef libérale à faire campagne
aujourd'hui seul sur le terrain un petit
commentaire à ce sujet de Saint José
ben je pense que là de toute évidence
Dominique Anglade va occuper le maximum
de terrain qu'elle peut possiblement
faire de toute évidence elle se sent
prête pour le débat de demain soir parce
que vraiment de faire ça la veille du
dernier des chefs c'était extrêmement
risqué mais
elle n'a plus soin elles sont elle est
vraiment vraiment une situation très
difficile écoutez même les temps danger
potentiellement même dans son propre
compte donc oui et puis on voit aussi un
virage stratégique qu'elle explique à la
population ce qui est un petit peu
bizarre quand même que l'on va voir la
vraie dominée donc c'était pas la vraie
convoyée avant je sais pas trop et donc
elle va laisser parler son cœur oui
qu'est-ce qu'elle pouvait bien vouloir
dire vous Sébastien qui avait suivi ça
toute la journée qu'est-ce qu'elle
voulait dire la vraie Dominique c'est
pas la vraie qu'on l'a vu jusqu'à
maintenant ce qu'on m'a présenté dans
les dernières heures c'est l'idée que
les gens les Québécois connaissent
Dominique Anglade la studieuse
ingénieurs la chef de partie mais ils
connaissent moins Dominique Anglade
près de ses émotions celles qui en
coulissent fait rire les gens autour
d'elle je veux pas vous faire une
description
très longue mais il pense que elle doit
parler il pense qu'il doit parler plus
avec ses émotions plus avec son cœur
être moins scripté peut-être moins dans
ces notes plus dans son émotion donc
c'était un aveu dans le fond que la
stratégie de début de campagne a pas
fonctionné et que là il faut changer de
stratégie pour présenter Dominique
Anglade sous un autre jour la vraie
Dominique comédie Michel est-ce que
c'était risqué pour elle aujourd'hui de
ne pas consacrer son temps comme les
autres des quatre quand les autres chefs
des quatre autres parties à se préparer
à ce débat qui pourrait être crucial
pour elle non
oui mais en même temps quand on est
obligé de changer de personnalité comme
elle est en train d'essayer de le faire
là en plein milieu d'une campagne il
faut aussi dire moi je ne fais pas des
choses comme tout le monde alors non moi
je veux pas passer deux jours à me faire
bombarder de questions dans une chambre
d'hôtel je vais parler aux gens vous
voyez je la nouvelle Dominique elle
parle aux citoyens
alors mais quand on est obligé de faire
ce changement de personnalité là puis
José disait très bien c'est que ça va
très mal et à 10 jours de la fin du de
la fin de la campagne
c'est un risque énorme et d'habitude
c'est fini mal mais la stratégie la
stratégie d'aujourd'hui Geneviève si
vous me permettez la stratégie
aujourd'hui quand même intéressante
c'est-à-dire d'être la seule à occuper
le terrain donc on en parle voilà on a
fait des reportages là dessus on
n'arrive pas d'en parler pendant toute
la journée et là on va peut-être porter
un peu plus attention à Dominique demain
pour voir la vraie Dominique alors que
au premier débat
qu'on se disait qu'elle était un peu
plus effacée qu'on portait un peu moins
attention donc là elle nous a quand même
accroché puis peut-être qu'on va la
regarder un peu plus de monde José un
petit mot
c'est exactement ce que j'allais dire
c'est à dire que là elle n'a pas de
concurrence pendant 24 heures quand même
ce qui arrive jamais dans une campagne
électorale pour pour un chef et surtout
qui sont simples maintenant donc oui et
comme le dit Sébastien il y a peut-être
un regard différent qui va se poser sur
elle au débat c'est ce qu'on verrait je
vous ferai je vous poserai la question
sur leur défi à chacun pour le débat de
demain soir mais juste revenir sur
dominés congelade au sujet de la réforme
du mode de scrutin on sait que les kakis
sont écartés il avait promis ils l'ont
écarté ils n'ont pas fait ils l'ont
écarté pour cette campagne-ci elle
maintenant se montre ouverte à ça alors
qu'une lettre de son parti disait que
non il n'était pas question il y a un
problème là au sein du Parti libéral
c'est je vous lance Sébastien là-dessus
il y a un problème oui quand le parti
écrit la semaine dernière au mouvement
démocratie nouvelle pour dire ça nous
intéresse on en parler puis que la chef
une semaine plus tard va sur la place
publique en disant qu'elle est ouverte à
la discussion il y a un problème il y a
un problème de coordination qui dit vrai
c'est le parti ou c'est la chef vont
Dominique Anglade retourne ça en disant
je vais faire preuve de leadership et je
vais en discuter à l'intérieur de mon
parti il faut pas opposer partir et chef
sauf que c'est ça qu'on fait c'est quand
même étonnant que Dominique Anglade
aujourd'hui dit en fait c'est un homme
si elle n'est pas nécessairement mais
c'est quand même quelque chose que
Dominique anglaise dise qu'elle soit
qu'elle est ouverte sur cette discussion
là alors que de tout temps le Parti
libéral a été très très réticent parce
que c'est un parti de pouvoir il était
porté au pouvoir parce ce système
électoral et là quand on voit que ils
sont menacés de peut-être même perdre
leur statut d'opposition officielle quoi
que c'est ouvert un débat c'est cette
possibilité là qu'il veuille peut-être
en parler on revient au principe que
quand tu es au pouvoir tu en parles pas
puis quand tu es dans l'opposition tu
souhaiterais en parler parce que ça
pourrait être avantageux Michel
là-dessus sur sur les contradictions
transparente en tout cas peut-être que
c'est la chef qui aura le dernier mot
finalement mais en tout cas faut dire
aussi que le Parti libéral a changé dans
les sondages il n'est plus qu'à quoi à
16% là
d'abord les trois parties que vous
regardez le Québec depuis la Révolution
tranquille l'ont tous promis à un moment
donné la proportionnelle ce sont tous
des dialogues il y a personne qui est
disponibilité plus grande que les autres
là-dessus j'enchaîne l'avait promis
après il a laissé tomber mais le Parti
libéral je vous avais raison là-dessus
et celui qui a été toujours le plus
réticent sauf que là on se dirige vers
si la tendance ce métier un parti qui va
avoir moins de 40% du vote puis
probablement quelque chose comme 80% des
députés l'élastique démocratique était
tiré beaucoup là alors que est
inévitable que la question de la
proportionnelle revienne sur le tapis à
ce moment-ci madame Magland a peut-être
pas dans
l'histoire du Parti libéral sur les
épaules est une nouvelle chef elle peut
dire ben on devrait regarder ça puis la
conjoncture fait que c'est intéressant
d'en parler mais moi je vois pas comment
partie justement qui aura gagné 80% des
sièges dire bah non c'est un mauvais
système
c'est ça parlons
de M je sais pas si ça vous tente d'en
parler en tout cas je pense qu'il misait
beaucoup dans les régions de Québec il y
avait sans doute là les plus grands
espoirs il y a un sondage aujourd'hui
qui lui donne 25% des intentions de vote
contre 48,7% pour la CAC parlant de
réforme du mode de scrutin avec 25% des
intentions de vote ça lui donnerait un
seul siège en tout cas est-ce que ça
vous surprend ça se sondage la jauge et
je commence avec vous
non pas vraiment parce que c'est un peu
son d'après ce qu'on peut évaluer on
verra évidemment le soir de l'élection
mais c'est un peu la taille de son noyau
dur qui est quand même pour rien
5%, c'est le cas quand même des
intentions de vote c'est qu'il est face
à une machine qui elle est massive aussi
dans la région donc la canne mais non
moi j'en suis pas étonné du tout et là
on revient encore une fois à un mode de
scrutin qui m'a produire probablement le
soir de l'élection des distorsions
vraiment majeures où on va avoir des
parties qui vont avoir eu un pourcentage
intéressant disons dans certaines
régions ou le calmer etc mais qui vont
être très très peu représentés à
l'Assemblée nationale donc mets-le le
chiffre lui-même j'ai l'impression je
peux me tromper là mais que monsieur
duem a fait le plein oui c'est
précisément la question que j'allais
poser à Michel est-ce que est-ce qu'il
est-ce que ça c'est
maximum 25% le quart des votes que
Monsieur dump peut espérer aller
chercher dans la grande région de Québec
je pense que oui je pense que les gens
qui avaient à voté pour monsieur John ce
sont déclarés les militants
conservateurs évidemment sont très
enthousiastes et sont très mobilisés
mais il s'est passé aussi d'autres
choses dans la campagne toute l'histoire
des contes de taxes pour payer c'est sûr
que ça peut aider monsieur duem mais
c'est des électeurs moins forcément
l'expression la crainquer que ces
partisans sont noyau dur de partisans
c'est pas sûr que ça l'a beaucoup aidé
et 25% quand de l'autre à 40 ça donne 0
député ça alors c'est c'est vraiment
iris d'arriver deuxième dans un grand
nombre de côtés de la région de Québec
et de ne pas avoir de siège c'est un
véritable danger sur la partie
conservatoire est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut dire aussi que si le PQ qui a gagné
des points après le premier débat là
c'est le PQ pourrait se faufiler dans la
région de Québec et nuire justement
parce qu'on savateur
dans ce sens là Sébastien oui il
pourrait aller chercher des votes
peut-être c'est de savoir à qui le Parti
québécois va chercher des votes est-ce
que c'était à la coalition Québec ou
c'est plutôt aux parties conservateur
j'ai plus l'impression que c'est à la
coalition à Québec qui va chercher des
votes dans la région de Québec à
vérifier mais le PQ fera pas lire en
tout cas il y a pas de certitude à part
la mort et les taxes dans la vie là mais
le Parti québécois je ne pense pas
pour qui mais
je pense pas que le Parti québécois va
faire élire des députés dans la région
de Québec peut-être qui peut jouer les
troubles fêtes à certains égards la
question est aussi de savoir si dans les
sondages les gens aux parties
conservateur pensent que leurs électeurs
sont discrets que leur sympathisants
sont discrets qui se sous manifeste en
fait c'est ça et que quand le téléphone
sonne c'est la même maison de sondage
ils osent pas dire qu'il va te
conservateur ça ça reste à démontrer
aussi mais c'est dur d'évaluer l'appui
au Parti conservateur ce qui est facile
de dire c'est que l'appui le plus fort
parce que conservateur c'est dans la
région de Québec dans la grande région
au Québec oui et si les chanceux Eric
dum ben vous savez le fameux convoi
anticap qui est censé débarquer dans le
comté du Premier ministre dans
l'Assomption
en fin de semaine
si les chanceux ça va être annulé il va
y avoir un problème parce que là on sait
pas les directeur général des élections
doit évaluer ce que ce sont des dépenses
hectares etc parce que si jamais il y
avait des rappels et il y a souvent des
rapages avec ces groupes là c'est sûr
que comme Monsieur dum en fait son pain
et son bain même s'il est pas à côté à
ce qu'on voit là avec ce genre de
supporter là
ça lui ferait pas nécessairement
beaucoup de bien j'aimerais vous
entendre maintenant tous les trois
rapidement à tour de rôle au sujet de la
campagne de monsieur Legault ces erreurs
ses excuses ses recul sa bonne foi je
m'excuse je suis désolé je voulais pas
faire ci dire ça comme ça c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise campagne un début
de campagne un début c'est plus qu'une
moitié de campagne maintenant José
oui ben c'est à dire il y a les deux
côtés il y a le côté téflon de monsieur
Legault parce que malgré tout même si
les intentions de vote de la CAF ont un
peu reculé
quand même vers une victoire importante
de la cacahuète vraiment de tremblement
de terre il y a ça donc ça touche pas et
en même temps non parce que il y a
consensus là c'est pas une bonne
campagne on moi cette semaine j'ai
trouvé qu'on sent pas sur son x je pense
que ça en est rendu compte surtout avec
le face à face de la semaine dernière où
il était toujours crispé il y avait
l'air malheureux il était agacé il y
avait l'air de vouloir être n'importe où
sauf là et là évidemment cette semaine
on le lui dire je vais être plus
souriant je vais faire ceci je vais
faire ça lui aussi peut-être qu'il va y
avoir le vrai François avec la vraie
Dominique je sais pas demain soir
c'est clair que c'est pas c'est pas une
bonne campagne mais parce qu'il était
long
c'est pas catastrophique contrairement à
Bernard Landry en 2003 qui avait eu une
très mauvaise campagne et lui ça lui a
coûté ça il y a pas fait de guerre après
le débat pendant le débat il y en a pas
perdu non plus Michel c'est vous êtes
d'accord avec la princesse c'est pas un
très très bonne campagne pour Monsieur
Lego mais il était flan
de campagne mais il faut pas oublier que
il a pas il a pas un chef politique des
dernières années au Québec qui a dominé
son parti autant que François Legault
lac c'est sa création il y a pas grand
monde qui rentre dans le bureau qui dit
bah ça marche pas les affaires monsieur
le beau vous êtes trompé ça n'arrive pas
dans la réalité des choses alors là il
arrive au débat il se fait dire toi tu
es pas bon tes affaires ne marchent pas
tu aurais pas dû faire si t'aurais pas
dû faire ça il a pas très bien réagi
probablement parce que il y a pas été
très habitué à se faire barbecer comme
ça pendant les quatre dernières années
ça arrive souvent à un premier ministre
sortant qui se retrouve pour la première
fois sur la défensive puis qu'il y a pas
l'air très sur la défensive mais
personne ne l'est vraiment alors c'est
un peu ce syndrome là
puis en plus sur des sujets qu'il n'aime
pas l'immigration par exemple il a le
don de ne pas bien expliquer et même de
dire le contraire de ce qui se passe des
fois alors ça c'est ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il s'excuse après qui aurait dû
durer une demi-journée alors il nous
reste quelques minutes une minute chacun
disons pour conclure je vais faire je
vais faire un pré débat avec vous je
vous demande et à tourneront à commencer
par vous Sébastien qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du débat demain soir du contenu
moins de cacophonie je vais surveiller
deux chefs François Legault qui dit
qu'il va être plus souriant on m'a dit
que il allait encaisser absorber les
attaques de ses adversaires parce que en
effet comme le disait Michel il est pas
habitué il a il recevait une clé une
gifle à gauche puis une gifle à droite
puis il devait garder le sourire et
c'est ce qu'il a l'intention de faire
semble-t-il demeure en parlant un peu
plus de son programme et Gabriel Nadeau
Dubois aussi il a très bien performé au
dernier débat donc les attentes sont
élevés est-ce qu'il est capable de
maintenir ce rythme ce sera à voir
dedans
oui et aussi pour saint-pierre-flamandon
chef du Parti québécois donc non on
s'attend pas à ce qui ce qui gagne ou ce
qui remporte le position officielle ou
quoi que ce soit mais il a fait une
bonne performance la semaine dernière
l'équipe sont en train de le découvrir
pour lui c'est ça va être intéressant de
surveiller pour qu'il ne brise pas
cet élan modeste là qu'il a enclenché et
vous Michel
je vais surveiller la nouvelle Dominique
parce que pour elle ça passe sous ça
casse et
changer la vraie
c'est très très risqué c'est très risqué
alors on verra tout ça on se souhaite on
se souhaite une excellente soirée de
main à l'antenne à notre antenne je vous
rappelle mesdames Messieurs que je vous
remercie tous les trois je vous ai le
goût Sébastien Bovet merci beaucoup à
tous les trois